check this out we've got from the daily
mail buffalo public school claims
all white people perpetuate systemic
racism and force
kindergartners to watch video of dead
black children
to warn them about racist police and
state-sanctioned violence
fatima morel is associate superintendent
for culturally and linguistically
responsive initiatives
at buffalo public schools in new york
morale has introduced a new curriculum
lesson plans
and teacher training the teachers are
encouraged encouraged to be more woke in
their efforts at anti-racism
morale suggests teaching kindergartner
classes about children killed by police
with videos featuring trayvon martin
tamir rice and others
older pupils pupils learn all white
people play a part in perpetuating
systemic racism
a whistleblower told city journal about
the news the new lessons new
lesson plans morell has yet to comment
on the controversial
uh new teaching programs i wonder if
they have some some photos
so there's one post where it says i am
ayana i was sleeping
i am trayvon i was walking anti-racism a
powerful collection of anti-racist
policies that lead to racial equity
and are substantiated by anti-racist
ideas they're indoctrinating kids
they're teaching kids this is illegal
the 1964 civil rights act says you can't
discriminate on the basis of race
these people they're being referred to
as neo-racist i just consider them
like good old passion yeah it's good
old-fashioned racist it's just it's the
same thing
it didn't change it's still racism
they're literally like that race is bad
okay well that you're racist
they're doing it in schools imagine the
psychology of a small
child hearing this and seeing just the
traumatic imagery
of death and then that being pushed
along with of course a big
propaganda we have to also understand
they use a lot of graphic images to push
this because when you're emotionally
shocked
when you're in a constant state of fear
you don't critically think
and for for kids to see something
traumatic and then be told hey
uh if you're white you're perpetrating
systemic racism no matter who you are
what you do because of the way you were
born that is just absolutely absurd
sickening and crazy
and destroying the youth of this nation
so there's this image that we've talked
about a bit before and i'm sure most of
you are familiar with it's the
the equity fence which uh is this meme
it's fairly viral and it looks like this
one got a
got a graphical update look at that very
very nice on the left it says equality
there is a tall man a medium-sized man
and a short well i don't know if they're
not a woman
person and they're all standing on a
crate
the short person can't see the fence is
in the way the the media person
can see over the fence and the tall
person can clearly see the next panel on
the right says equity
now the tall person has no crate so he
but he can still see he's tall
the person in the middle still has one
crate but the short person now has two
another short person can see the
baseball game as well my favorite
response this is from libertarians where
they say they're all stealing they are
they're all stealing because there's you
can pay for tickets but i want to point
something out
when they're teaching kids about this
stuff and they show this image
what they're not explaining to the kids
because all the people here are brown
skinned they're all of the same race
what they're not telling you is in on
the side that says equity
where you have the three people standing
up imagine the tall person
is of one particular race then imagine
someone from the government
taking away from that person and giving
it to someone else
based on their race now imagine that the
person who is tall
is actually a black person and the
person who is short as a white person
would you justify the government coming
and taking from the black community to
give
to the white community their argument is
well we just
know who is quantifiably privileged or
underprivileged
but you don't know would it make sense
for the government to take away from
like a working class
you know white family where the dad is a
carpenter and the mom
is is you know is it auto sales a car
sales person and they take money from
them and give it to
oprah's family well this is meaningless
well this is the thing we even had
one of the head board members of the new
york city education
organization publicly come out and say
if there's a rich
or middle class black person and a poor
white kid
resources have to go to the middle class
rich black person because of systemic
historic racism so we have literal heads
of education in new york city arguing
for this
and there's a third uh meme that that's
related to the beam that you have
up there and it's a third panel and it
says when government
gets involved and it shows the tall
person and
the the middle person getting their legs
chopped off
as a representation of whenever the
government gets involved that i tweeted
a long time ago which i think is also
perfectly representative of what
actually happens when the government
tries to solve a problem that
usually they're the ones that
perpetrated it and created it
they usually make it a lot worse so i i
can't find it i'm trying to find it
there's a bunch of silly versions of
this though there's like liberation
there's no fence anymore i like that one
because it makes no sense
because there's like so does the
outfield go forever apparently so it's
like the
outfielders can keep running and there's
no home run so long it doesn't matter
it's all an rbi
yeah the rules don't matter they're
teaching kids this stuff and they're not
teaching kids enough to explain
anything to them about what it really
means it's just indoctrination
these kids are going to grow up as
dogmatic tribalists
i'll tell you what's funny they they
many on the left had similar things
about religion
you know back in the day kids growing up
with religious indoctrination oh it's a
problem i don't care sure fine i'll tell
you what
it doesn't justify you becoming the
dogmatic religious lunatics
but i tell you it's really crazy
watching this
cult spread there's an organic
organization called free press the free
press
it's called free press.net i used to
know these guys i've
i actually only a few years ago was
sitting down with one of the guys from
the free press
talking about freedom of speech freedom
of of the press our ability to
communicate
and then in the past year two years the
organization has called for banning
and censoring misinformation and the
far-right and political ideas they don't
like and i'm like
how have you gone so insane with this
cult that an organization
called the free press would launch a
campaign to
censor people based on their opinions
well we saw democrats in congress
recently write that letter talking about
uh banning fox news and
one america it's just it's it's really
really concerning and tucker carlson
uh he he's been one of the main targets
uh from media matters and and what have
you and so
he's really been sounding the alarm on
that and it really is becoming a
big problem in terms of rhetoric that
we're seeing from
people in power yeah and so it's just
it's
it's completely absurd just because it's
cnn and msnbc they do how do you how do
you fight
this kind of thing right it's like it's
like a religion home school uh
this i mean reading this article really
really uh made me proud of understanding
the larger homeschool network in new
hampshire that
that that happens in that particular
state it's one of the largest
homeschooling states and also the the
smartest state compared to of course iqs
of other states
which tells you a lot because when you
give up your child to the institution of
the state for quote education
they're not you're not really getting
educated you're getting indoctrinated
into the propaganda
this is this the newest level of
propaganda that they're introducing
people
so they could go along with their bigger
agenda the newer agenda
but of course there was an older agenda
the school system
has failed our children it has failed me
it has failed a large number of
individuals and it's not there to uplift
people it's not there to help people
find their skills their passions their
loves it's not there to help people
in their journeys in life it's there to
keep them in institutions so they could
be good factory workers
and that's what school systems were
built on by the rockefeller institute
trying to of course rinse and repeat
create good factory workers what was it
michael malus who said that
one of the only places a child will
experience violence will be in a school
with what michael said yeah and uh i'm
not sure if it was michael who said this
but someone said they're effectively
prisons
yeah yeah yeah yeah michael said that
yeah and uh
i agree um i mean i think schools public
schools particularly i've been a private
school
private school i i went to catholic
school for the first you know up until
fifth grade and then sixth grade i
transferred to public school
public school is just awful there's like
limited supervision they don't care the
kids are not really learning things it
was just really really bad
i mean i saw extreme amounts of violence
uh in new york city there was a kid that
got shot in my classroom
like i can't even go into just some of
the graphic details of what i saw
growing up there but essentially when
you really look at it
it's run like a prison the same
companies that build the schools or the
same companies that
also build the prisons i remember
visiting my friend in prison just a few
months ago and being like
this looks a lot like my school and then
i remember like oh yeah
they work for the same kind of
contracting organizations that build
these larger institutions and it's not
just the construction of these
uh buildings it's also the way that
they're run it's also the
the way that teachers bark orders that
students scream at them tell them to
stay in line tell them to
to regurgitate whatever they say and if
they don't have the same opinions as
they do
they get punished and essentially even
in college
if you have a opinion that a professor
doesn't like they're going to give you a
worse grade than if you had a you know
opinion that actually
disagreed with them think about where
the school stuff leads to right check it
out
you're going to have right now you've
got all these teacher unions saying
we're not reopening we're not going to
go back to work
we don't want to go back to school but
pay us not essential sure they say but
we want to make sure the schools are
safe i
really just don't believe you fine
whatever they don't want to reopen
schools
wealthier families are just
homeschooling their kids and they're
putting them in learning pods
where they hire tutors the tutor gets 20
to 30 kids
that tutor's probably making bank to be
honest because all these parents are now
like
pay a hundred bucks a week or something
and they got 30 kids so these tutors are
just raking in the dough
teaching a various group of kids
throughout the day these kids are
getting one-on-one education in a small
classroom
with a professional edu you know
educator to some degree
these kids when they get older they're
gonna be smarter better
faster stronger all of these things
because they're getting well they're
getting
invested in these other kids who are
going to these schools are being
indoctrinated
are going to be well they're being kept
out of school they're being given given
very awful uh education they're getting
these zoom classes most the kids don't
even pay attention
they're not going to school the teachers
don't care the teachers don't want to be
there the teachers are arguing keeping
the school shut down
and then when they are there they're
getting indoctrinated with garbage so
what happens
you're going to end up with two
20-year-olds one 20-year-old
from the pods from the learning pods not
the not the
dystopian pods and they're going to be
sitting there and they're going to be
socially savvy
they'll have grown up around adults
they'll have learned the intricacies of
you know
normal human living and they're gonna
have a conversation with an employer and
say
you know i i worked very hard i was you
know i ran my family's business when i
was 18 i did this
i was educated at these you know these
institutions i did homeschool for these
years
and they're going to be like oh this
person's articulate you know well
thought out
i think they can bring a lot to my
company and they're going to look at the
next resume and the person's going to be
like
well i am a person of color and it means
you have to hire me
and um i didn't go to school because the
teachers didn't want to show up
but i did learn about equity from
watching mtv videos on youtube
and they're going to be like uh i'm not
going to hire you
like you don't bring value now the one
thing that could change that of course
is if we get really extreme leftist
draconian woke policy where the
companies like in california are forced
to bring on
you know women and minorities to their
board so that's like if your company is
of a certain size you
have to fire a white guy and then hire a
woman of color or something
so then maybe that will actually happen
where you're going to have people show
up and they're going to be like
well you have to hire me so there you go
and then you end up like venezuela
i mean i know venezuela's kind of the
go-to example but
in venezuela man they make jobs for the
sake of making jobs you know
they don't need a job well well just
make it and just there could be a job
for one person
let's say the job the example i often
give is when i was trying to buy a cell
phone in venezuela
it was like five different people i had
to talk to buy a cell phone
because they just created the jobs
because they need to have jobs
in the us you walk into a t-mobile or an
att or a sprint there's one person
you're like yeah i want to phone like
okay they
bought the phone they sign you up you
give them a credit card they say bye-bye
the amount of mandatory signage that
businesses need in venezuela is
absolutely ridiculous
they at least they have to dedicate an
entire wall to all the permits
to all the regulations to all the rules
and also a huge
no smoking sign and a huge no guns are
welcome here sign
in caracas venezuela at one time the
murder capital of the world
and it's not anymore it fluctuates
between
other latin american countries uh but
when i went there it was the number one
murder capital in the entire world
they outlawed people having firearms and
guess what
homicides through firearms skyrocketed
because all the people were disarmed and
only the criminals had the firearms
even private security in some instances
wasn't allowed to have
firearms and the police officers were
working with of course politically
motivated institutions and groups that
protected each other
meanwhile other people were left to of
course the gangs
and i forgot the exact name of this one
motorcycle gang that was wreaking havoc
on a whole bunch of communities but
but again when you go to venezuela it's
been wrecked by absolute violence to the
point where
police officers and other authorities
were literally telling me hey if you're
driving at night
and uh there's a red light just don't
don't worry
don't stop just go right up ahead yeah i
was i was a dirty smoker at the time too
and the hotel was like no no
no no no no smoke here i'm like okay
i'll go over there they're like no no no
no no no no you're gonna get killed
there i'm like what do you want me to do
i'm gonna smoke too now i'm gonna screw
you man like call us
i'm all nervous yeah i'm even more
nervous i don't smoke anymore
uh that was a bad phase that i had don't
smoke it's really bad for you
but but again it just shows you the
utter lunacy of more government
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast monday through friday at 8 p.m
where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you